so now you've saved a lot of words
created links you've saved i hope
phrases and you're probably wondering
how you can possibly review all of these
words
the good news is you don't have to
review them all in fact if you're
creating a lot of links as i always do i
can't possibly review them all you
review some of them
you can review them
after each page when you're reading you
can go to the vocabulary page and select
a different group of words to review
you can choose which of the different
activities you want to use uh
you know flash cards multiple choice
dictation reverse flash cards
it's it's more
an opportunity to increase your
attentiveness to the language especially
if you create tags even creating tags
focuses your attention on these words
and phrases but don't think you can
review them all you can review some of
them and spend most of your time
enjoyably listening and reading and
seeing all of your links show up in
yellow and eventually they turn to white